For the most part, the cast of Avengers: Endgame
was in the dark just as much as the fans when
it came to the movie's plot developments.
Here's how they reacted when they got the
news about what would be happening to Earth's
Mightiest Heroes in the war against Thanos.
One of the most crowd-pleasing moments of
Avengers: Endgame comes when Tony Stark channels
Black Sabbath one last time before wiping
out Thanos and his forces with the Infinity
Stones.
"I am Iron Man."
The move wins the day for the good guys with
a fantastic callback, bringing the series
full circle in what some fans would call a
"crowning moment of awesome."
It's just a perfect line for Tony, and one
that wasn't in the script.
After Endgame was released, directors Anthony
and Joe Russo revealed the line was added
to the movie in reshoots, after editor Jeff
Ford realized a response was needed for Thanos'
final declaration of "I am inevitable."
The Russos brought Downey to dinner to pitch
the reshoot, with Hollywood super-producer
Joel Silver also tagging along.
According to the Russos, Downey's reaction
to his character's death was so powerful that
he resisted being brought back to face it
again.
They recalled him being hesitant, saying.
"I don't know.
I don't really want to go back and get into
that emotional state."
"Just when I thought I was out, they pull
me back in."
It was apparently Silver an old friend of
Downey's who managed to change his mind.
According to the Russos, he responded to the
actor's doubts with,
"Robert, what are you talking about?
That's the greatest line I've ever heard!
You gotta say this line!
You have to do this!"
And like a snap, it was done.
"How 'bout that?"
Speaking to Jimmy Fallon on The Tonight Show,
Winter Soldier actor Sebastian Stan discussed
how tight the secrecy was while filming Endgame
even more so than usual.
When asked if he ever had any idea of what
exactly he was filming, Stan said,
"Not for this one we didn't.
I mean, everything I filmed I found out on
the day."
He also joked that he concealed his confusion
with some of that smoldering Winter Soldier
charisma.
"You can kinda tell behind my expression,
I hide the confusion well, under a Zoolander
look."
Stan referred specifically to one of Endgame's
final scenes when the surviving heroes gather
for Tony Stark's memorial.
According to Stan, he was initially told it
was a very different type of ceremony.
"I was told it was a wedding, that there was
a wedding that we were filming.
And I was like, 'Who's getting married?'"
Throughout the Guardians of the Galaxy movies,
Drax has demonstrated that you don't need
a lot of words to say how you really feel.
Dave Bautista proved the same point with his
brief but telling response to Avengers: Endgame.
In an April 29 post, the Drax actor tweeted,
"Annnnnd...still processing."
Drax doesn't appear in Endgame until the final
battle, so considering the secrecy and misdirection
used on actors like Mark Ruffalo, whose characters
were more important to the overall plot, it
isn't likely Bautista knew much about what
happened in the movie outside scenes he filmed.
His reactions were likely just like the ones
felt by most of the audience.
His "processing" may also revolve around what
it all means for Drax's future in the MCU.
With the death of Thanos a death which, let's
remember, has very little to do with Drax's
actions in the film Bautista's character's
chief motivation is gone.
"Yes.
Of course, Ronan was only a puppet.
It's really Thanos I need to kill."
Then there's the fact that, at the end of
Endgame, Thor seemed to be joining the cast
of Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3.
As such, it's safe to imagine that at least
some of Bautista's processing might be of
a professional nature.
After all, Drax is a big strong guy who says
funny things.
Thor is a big strong guy who says funny things.
Do you really need two?
Then again, maybe he's just processing that,
in the next film, he gets to work in such
a beautiful creature's presence:
"He is not a dude.
You're a dude.
This, this is a man.
A handsome, muscular man."
Leave it to Star-Lord to do the exact opposite
of what he's supposed to do.
"What are you doing?"
"Dance off, bro!
Me and you!"
On the set of Endgame, while taking some downtime
during filming the movie's climactic final
battle, Chris Pratt took out his phone and
knowingly broke all the rules he started recording.
"This is a really illegal video."
The star posted the video to his Instagram
account on May first, and it's a regular who's
who of MCU actors, folks who are now some
of the most famous performers on the planet.
When it came to one of the biggest moments
in the movie, Pratt's first thought was to
make sure, quote, "no rule was going to stop"
him from capturing and sharing it.
And it's kind of tough to blame him.
Chris Evans ends the video by playfully telling
his costar that he's in:
"Big trouble."
"Big time."
But it's Sean Gunn, who motion-captures Rocket
Raccoon, who has the best line in the clip:
"I'm pretty sure I'm the most famous person
here."
One of Endgame's biggest moments didn't take
place on the screen or behind the cameras;
it happened in the record books.
In early May, Avengers: Endgame knocked 1997's
Titanic out of the #2 spot on the list of
highest-grossing films in box office history.
The development didn't go unnoticed by Titanic
director James Cameron, who issued a social
media congratulations to the MCU.
Posting a picture on Instagram of a ship sunk
by a half-submerged Avengers logo rather than
an iceberg, Cameron accompanied the image
with:
"An iceberg to sank the real Titanic.
It took The Avengers to sink my Titanic…You've
shown that not only is the movie industry
alive and well.
It's bigger than ever!"
Don Cheadle, who plays War Machine, responded
to Cameron's classy congrats with a now-deleted
tweet that read, "Nothing personal, James…it's
the fans," and a shrugging emoji.
Judging by the responses Cheadle's tweet received,
the snark has not been overlooked.
Cameron rubbed superhero movie fans the wrong
way in April 2018, when he told Indiewire
he was hoping for what he called, quote, "Avenger
fatigue."
Cameron said he liked the movies, but
"...there are other stories to tell besides
hyper-gonadal males without families doing
death-defying things for two hours and wrecking
cities in the process."
Perhaps now Cameron is relieved Endgame has
come and gone, so that those "hyper-gonadal
males" will leave for a bit and give Cameron
a chance to show us some Terminator movies
with, uh, Arnold Schwarzenegger.
Downey, Bautista, and Cheadle all showed us
how only a few words can say so much.
Hawkeye actor Jeremy Renner went a bit further,
and reinforced that old adage about a picture
and how many stories it can tell on its own.
Renner's mother accompanied him to the Avengers:
Endgame premiere.
The next day, Renner posted a touching photo
of himself holding his mother and appearing
very emotional; perhaps even in tears.
Renner wrote:
"Wow…words will only betray my feelings
for this movie…this picture from last night
represents…love…pride of my family, my
friends, and crazy for my avenger family."
Renner didn't mention any specific scenes
or aspects of the film that put him in such
a vulnerable state, but anyone who has seen
Endgame probably has an easy time imagining
more than a few things that could leave the
Avengers' favorite archer in tears.
One of the biggest moments of Avengers: Endgame's
resolution is when the aged Steve Rogers passes
his shield to Falcon.
It's a welcome, crowd-pleasing moment toward
the end of the film.
Apparently, Anthonie Mackie was one of the
last to know it was going to happen.
Fittingly, Mackie said the moment he learned
about it was an interesting reflection of
what we see on the screen.
Mackie told IMDb:
"I didn't even know it was happening.
We were at his house and he goes, 'You excited?'
I went, 'What you talking about?'
He goes, 'Wait, you don’t know?'"
At that point, Mackie says Evans ran out of
the room and returned with the script for
Mackie to read.
"And I read the scene and I’m like, ‘Oh,’
and he goes, ‘Yes' We cried, we drank, we
laughed, it became this thing."
He went on to express his gratitude that he
got to spend that kind of moment with Evans,
and it sounds like he got a good laugh out
of getting the news later than everyone else.
"Don’t look at me.
I do what he does, just slower."
Anthony Mackie may have been grateful for
the moment he had with Chris Evans where he
was passed Cap's shield, but a lot of fans
were the exact opposite of grateful when the
Captain America actor talked about his reaction
to Avengers: Endgame with The Hollywood Reporter
a month before the film's theatrical release.
Evans told THR he, quote, "choked up like
three times."
A month later, at Endgame's L.A. premiere,
Evans boosted that number to six.
The original THR interview upset fans about
the prospect of being upset.
The news that the movie made one of the stars
cry had some asking how they were to cope.
"I'm very upset!
You know what I like about being upset?
Blame!"
What really set the fans on fire was Evans'
joke during the THR interview about his own
character's supposed death.
The interview ends with Evans joking,
"It's hard.
Seeing my own death.
It's going to be a long movie, that's for
sure.
The first edit clocked in over three hours.
My funeral's like an hour."
Some fans went so far as to direct some less
than polite words at the actor for joking
about Cap dying, but plenty of others had
a good sense of humor about it.
Along with big moments that happened in Endgame,
we've also seen some fun reactions to moments
that fortunately (or unfortunately, depending
on your tastes) didn't happen.
Like the so-called "ThanusTheory," which guessed
that Ant-Man would defeat Thanos by shrinking,
entering the Mad Titan's butt, and then switching
to Giant Man size.
UK talk show host Graham Norton asked Paul
Rudd about the theory, and both Norton and
fellow guest Chris Hemsworth pointed out the
tactic would work.
But apparently not in love with the idea,
Rudd asked,
"Why not the ear or the nose?
I mean, why does it have to be…?"
The Titan himself got to comment on the theory
when Variety asked Josh Brolin about it at
the Endgame premiere.
Referring to an Instagram post he'd made earlier
that day featuring an artist's rendering of
naked Thanos' backside, Brolin dodged addressing
the theory directly, instead choosing to celebrate
the Mad Titan’s impressive physique.
"That's a peach, man, that's a peach.
That's a purple peach if I've ever seen one,
that's a beautiful, purple peach."
In the aftermath of Endgame's release, one
of the film's most polarizing aspects was
the appearance of so-called "Fat Thor."
Five years after the Decimation and Thanos'
death at the hands of Thor, the thunder god
is revealed to be in dire emotional straits.
Thor is depicted as having done little for
the past few years but eat, drink heavily,
and play video games.
"Thor!"
"Is he asleep?"
Regardless of the debate about the character's
Endgame trajectory and how it was handled,
we know now that Hemsworth was excited about
it.
In an interview with Sirius XM, directors
Joe and Anthony Russo shared how they pitched
Hemsworth their plans over the phone for Fat
Thor.
Anthony said during the call,
"[Hemsworth] was so energized by the work
he had done [in Thor:Ragnarok] in terms of
coming up with a more comedic and irreverent
Thor."
That's when Joe Russo chimed in, saying,
"'Wait until you hear what we've got for you.'"
"I think I'm having a panic attack."
"Get it together!"
Considering Hemsworth has said he was bored
with playing Thor before Ragnarok re-energized
his interest, it's a safe bet that if he continues
in the MCU, Hemsworth is going to want to
keep charting new territory for the thunder
god.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.